Kanye West now legally yay was recently
restricted from Instagram and Twitter
after posting anti-semitic rants he's
set to bipolar the conservative
uncancelable Free Speech platform parlor
is popular among white supremacists and
far-right extremists who can freely post
hate speech and spread conspiracy
theories without fear of restrictions or
bans the platform was used to coordinate
the January 6 Insurrection and spread
content that glorified the violence that
took place the CEO of the company George
farmer is married to Candace Owens the
conservative influencer who recently
appeared at Paris fashion week with yay
wearing matching White lives matter
shirts they have been on a bit of a
Twitter hiatus but returned to spread
harmful stereotypes and violent threats
against Jewish people after being
restricted on Instagram for similar
posts though Elon Musk the potential
next owner of Twitter seemed thrilled by
yea's return an agreement in principle
has been reached to sell parlor to yay
for an undisclosed amount aiming to
close the deal by the end of the year
farmer said yay is making a
groundbreaking move into the Free Speech
media space and will never have to fear
being removed from social media again
[Music]